nous vous en parlions déjà dans notre
édition d'hier des chercheurs viennent
de découvrir que les gravures laissaient
sur les parois de la grotte de la
roche-cotard à Langeais d'après il y a
plus de 57
000 ans ses inscriptions seraient donc
bien plus anciennes que celle des grotes
Chauvet ou de Lascaux une découverte
aussi pour les 4500 habitants de ce
village plutôt connu pour son château
Aurélie Renaud et Juliette Tissier
un kilomètre et demi du centre ville de
Langeais nous sommes près de l'enceinte
du château de la roche-cotard c'est ici
que se trouve les gravures pariétales
les plus anciennes d'Europe réalisée
avec les doigts sur des parois calcaires
elle pourrait dater de plus de 57.000
ans et pourrait même remonter à 75000
ans la nouvelle a fait les gros titres
de la presse à Langeais si les habitants
découvrent à peine l'information il
accueille avec grand enthousiasme j'ai
partagé l'info à ma famille moi parce
que c'est quand même une nouvelle
incroyable et puis quand on dit plus
vieux que la grotte de Chauvet voilà ça
marque quoi
c'est clair c'est vrai que ça donnerait
envie de d'aller voir j'aimerais bien
aller voir honnêtement c'est privé
j'espère qu'ils vont faire des des
ouvertures exceptionnelles ou pour au
moins les locaux pour les professionnels
pour qu'on puisse en parler après
derrière d'ailleurs ça serait bien très
intéressant parce que c'est vrai qu'avec
notre beau château ça pourrait être un
complément de visite pour tous ces
touristes c'est très intéressant
sur cette reconstitution numérique
publiée par la revue scientifique plus
one on découvre une galerie de 12 mètres
de long selon les différentes études les
traces sont bien ornementales des formes
délibérées créées par la main de l'homme
des gravures pariétales qui deviennent
un trésor qu'il faudra préserver
57000 années rendez-vous compte ce que
c'est pour nous qui sommes dans
l'immédiateté donc ça nous fait
évidemment plaisir il faudra qu'on voit
comment on peut la faire connaître bien
évidemment en la préservant
les grottes pariétales seront-elles un
jour ouverte au public pas de réponse
pour le moment le lieu est très étroit
de plus il est situé sur une parcelle
privée